موسكو الوجهه الاولى للرئيس الصيني بعد
اعاده انتخابه لخمسه اعوام قادمه كما فعل
قبل عشر سنوات تماما وشيجين بنك اول قاده
العالم يلتقي بوتين بعد اصدار الجنائيه
الدوليه مذكره توقيف بحقه تقول بيجين ان
زياره شيجليموسكو هي من اجل السلام تلمح
بذلك الى مقترح صيني لتسويه الازمه بين
روسيا واوكرانيا السلميا كشفت عنه الصين
في الذكرى الاولى للحرب ورقه من 12 بندا
صيغه على مبدا انه لا حلول بسيطه للمشاكل
المعقده هكذا وصف الرئيس الشيشين بينج
مقترحه للسلام في اوكرانيا يدعو المقترح
الصيني الى احترام سياده كل الدول وعدم
السعي لتحقيق امن دوله ما على حساب دول
اخرى وقف القتال واستئناف محادثات السلام
حل الازمه الانسانيه وحمايه المدنيين
واسرى الحرب تجنب خوض ح النوويه او حتى
التهديد باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه تسهيل
تصدير الحبوب والحفاظ على استقرار الصناعه
وسلاسل التوريد وقف العقوبات الاحاديه
وتطبيق القانون الدولي بشكل موحد والتخلي
عن المعايير المزدوجه ما بين ترحيب حذر
وتشكيك في نيات بيجين تفاوتت ردود الفعل
بالنسبه للغرب فان الصين قالت كل شيء في
مقترحها دون ان تلتزم باي شيء فهي لم تطرح
جدلا زمنيا لمحادثات السلام ولم تقدم عرضا
لاستضافه اي مفاوضات بين موسكو وثم من يرى
ان المبادره الصينيه اقرب لمرافعه دفاع
للرد على الاتهامات الغربيه وتحديدا
الامريكيه لبيجين بالسعي للانخراط في
الحرب دعما لروسيا قالت واشنطن فريق
المشككين يرى الرئيس جو بايدن ان ما تقدمه
الصين خطه مفصله تلبي اهواء بوتين
بتوفير غطاء دبلوماسي لروسيا كي تواصل
جرائمها في اوكرانيا وتطالب بخطوات لبناء
الثقه كان تسخر الصين نفوذها على روسيا
لسحب قواتها من اوكرانيا اما الناتو فيقول
انه لامس دقيه لدوله لم تدن حرب بوتين على
اوكرانيا بعين الشك ذاتها ينظر الاتحاد
الاوروبي لمبادره الرئيس الصيني فالى الان
لم تقدم الصين ما يقنع الاوروبيين بانها
قادره على اداء دور بناء من اجل السلام في
اوكرانيا تخالف لندن جيرانها الاوروبيين
بالقول انها تثق بان بيجين رغبه في انتهاء
الحرب بالنسبه للرئيس الاوكراني
فان تفكير الصين الحليف لروسيا في التوسط
للسلام امر مبشر يقول زيلينسكي انما قدمته
بيجين ليس مبادره او خطه حقيقيه بقدر ما
هي افكار تقبل كييف بعضها وترفض بعضا بشكل
قاطع فاي خطه الحرب لابد ان تشمل انسحاب
القوات الروسيه الى حدود اوكرانيا عام
1991 في وقت تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي
بالنسبه
فان ايمانا الرئيس الصيني بمبدا السياده
ووحده اراضي الدول يجب ان يكون دافعا له
كي يقنع روسيا بالانسحاب من اراضي
اوكرانيا في المقابل ترى موسكو ان تمت
حقائق جديده على الارض يجب على كييف ان
تقبل بها وان رحب بوتين بمبادره حليفه
الصيني فانه لن يتنازل عما تنزعه بقوه
السلاح خلال عام من الحرب